Привет! За три модуля ты прошёл большой путь, собрал стратегию, PRD, поставил дизайн-систему, экраны, сделал визуал.
Но пока это всё только живёт у нас в Figma, это сильная заготовка, из которой мы можем собрать уже полноценный продукт,
то, чем можно пользоваться, собирать метрики и так далее. И сделать мы это можем сами, без разработчиков.
Благодаря тому, что мы действовали в одной среде, у нас есть полный контекст продуктов, у нас есть связь среды и Figma,
то есть, у нас описаны все возможные компоненты, переменные токены, стили и так далее.
На этом же самом фундаменте мы будем собирать прототип. Делать это так, чтобы точно так же основывалось на том,
что у нас в среде, что у нас в Figma, то есть, у нас получалась зеркальная копия того, что у нас в Figma, того, что у нас в Prode.
Не только в плане визуала, а в плане того, как там называются компоненты, какие стили и параметры у них установлены и так далее.
Всё это для того, чтобы экраны выглядели максимально консистентно, ну и, в принципе, это был
полноценный продакшн-уровень. И, в принципе, для вот этого рабочего продукта, для этого
прототипа у нас есть несколько применений. Возможно, мы просто хотим что-то потыкать,
посмотреть, показать команде свою идею, её уже предфинальную реализацию, чтобы можно было легче, быстрее эту идею защитить.
Пожалуйста. Второй вариант - это если мы хотим сразу в прот катнуть этот самый прототип, сразу внедрить в свой продукт, отдать это пользователям,
полностью интегрировать, отдать пользователям. И здесь это уже часть полноценной разработки.
Это тоже нужно сделать правильно, есть ряд нюансов, об этом мы поговорим. И третий вариант - это когда на
прототипе мы хотим провести тестирование своих решений. Мы раньше то же самое делали в Figma, теперь мы можем
делать это намного быстрее и качественнее с помощью таких прототипов. Большой плюс таких прототипов в том, что они
предусматривают много edge-кейсов, нестандартных поведений, валидацию, которую в Figma прототипе либо очень сложно предусмотреть, либо вообще невозможно.
Здесь же там та же форма, например, у тебя будет полноценная, интерактивная с теми форматами ввода полей, там кнопочка у тебя будет disabled по умолчанию, когда всё правильно, её можно будет нажать и так далее.
Агент такие базовые механики предусматривает самостоятельно, делает их ровно такими, какими пользователь потом будет их видеть в конечном продукте.
Что, конечно, значительно сказывается на качестве U-тестов. И помимо того, что подход к U-тестам мы значительно обновляем за счёт того, что больше не делаем это где-нибудь в Figma, а собираем полноценный рабочий прототип, также и подход к сбору результатов U-тестов мы значительно обновляем.
Если из Figma ты нормально никакие метрики не выдернешь, а катнуть в прот и потом смотреть, как пользуются люди, требует огромного количества времени, здесь же мы сами собираем этот самый прот и подрубаем к нему свой отдельный дашборд, который метрики будет собирать.
На каких экранах пользователь оставался, проходит ли он по тому юзерфлоу, который мы ожидали и так далее. Всё это будет представлено в удобном дашборде, где мы сможем оценить своё решение. Соответственно, в этом случае мы автоматизируем и сборку прототипа, и сбор метрик, что, по-моему, очень удобно.
Итак, прототипирование — это уже, по сути, кодинг. Если мы говорим о кодинге, здесь у нас есть несколько вариаций. В принципе, для агентских задач также эти инструменты можно было использовать, но здесь давайте ещё раз закрепим, что мы используем и почему.
По большому счёту, на данный момент на рынке три серьёзных конкурента — кодекс, курсор, клод-код. Это то, что действительно достойно вашего внимания, остальное, ну, оно приходит и уходит.
Итак, кодекс — это OpenAI, от них же ChatGPT. Он дешевле, чем клод-код, он делает неплохой результат, но я, например, тестирую его практически после каждого обновления, и, да, действительно, он улучшается, он может всё больше, результат всё круче, но всё-таки, да, к лоду он не дотягивает.
Курсор — это такая более хайповая штука. Это как антигравити уже профессионального разработчика. Он работает стабильнее, он более адаптирован под процессы именно разработки.
Но там подписочная модель. Чтобы курсором пользоваться, тебе нужна подписка. В этой подписке ты получаешь и клод, и GPT-модели, и другие.
Получается, ты платишь за то, чтобы у тебя вот в этом плане был выбор из разных моделей, но нужен ли здесь этот выбор?
Если лучше всех, всегда работает клод. Я считаю, что не нужен.
Так или иначе, штука неплохая. Если тебя каким-то образом обязывают пользоваться именно им, это не повод расстраиваться.
Ты в нём также разберёшься. В принципе, там флоу взаимодействия тот же самый.
Ну и клод-код — то, чем мы будем пользоваться. Более того, мы его уже оплатили в рамках этого курса.
И в целом это самый сильный инструмент, на мой взгляд, как под агентские задачи, так и под задачи кодинга.
Теперь пройдёмся по тому, что в итоге будет в этом модуле.
Во-первых, мы сначала разберёмся, из чего состоит кодинг, продакшн на таком более поверхностном уровне.
Всё-таки мы и тут дизайнер, мы не пытаемся стать профессиональными разработчиками, но понимать механики, понимать, как это вообще работает, что это такое нужно, чтобы общаться с разработчиком, ну хотя бы плюс-минус на одном языке.
И в целом понимать, какие у тебя ограничения, что тебе использовать для создания тех или иных продуктов.
Ведь у нас есть сайты, веб-приложения, мобильные приложения и так далее.
Также в код-коде выстроим взаимосвязь прода и дизайна.
Разберёмся, что такое React. Это фреймворк, которым мы будем работать.
Разберёмся, почему именно в нём.
Рассмотрим, как делать деплой, как арендовать сервер, закинуть этот продукт на свой сервер, чтобы вообще кто угодно мог к нему подойти.
Также подрубим дэшборд, будем собирать метрики.
После чего у нас в заключительные последние уроки мы прошли огромный путь, собрали практически свой продукт, первую его итерацию, ну в зависимости от того, как сильно ты углублялся в рамках выполнения курсовых работ.
И как теперь весь этот опыт оформить в полноценную среду, с которой ты можешь двигаться дальше, уже со скиллами и всем остальным.
Ну и в конечном итоге обсудим курсовую, она же уже выпускная, поскольку модуль последний, завершающий.
И на этом всё.
Итак, этот урок вводный, мы пробежались по тому, что будет в модуле, что мы будем использовать.
Сразу хочу сказать, что будет много непонятных новых слов, тут я хочу, чтобы ты просто к этому подготовился.
Всё-таки нужно хотя бы поверхностно в этом разобраться, чтобы потом уже нормально ставить задачи агенту и потом уже понимать, если что-то не работает, что именно идёт не так.
Поэтому модуль, наверное, самый впечатляющий по результатам, которые мы от него получим.
Сначала закроем теорию, а потом соберём, наконец-то, наш продукт.
На этом всё.
До встречи в следующем уроке.
Пока.